google で検索するぐぐのような
新しい同士をいくつか作ってみた喧嘩して
いる友達の板挟みになることミドルラック
ダック号で検索することアヒルクリック
ベイトだけで再生数を稼ごうとすること
サムネイル不満と怒りを撃ち殺すこと
ボトルコーヒー中得になることシアトル
メタバースから現実に戻ることリアル自分
はものがほとんどないことを定期的に自慢
することミニマルマイバッグを家に忘れて
しまうことビニールヒマさえあれば
ティックとこう見ること無懈対して食べて
いないスーパーフードの写真をインスタに
up することka るネットで綺麗な人
を見かけたらすぐに新しいタブを開くこと
兄もある政治家が不公平なことを変な理屈
でごまかそうとすることロジカル通知が
来ることベル久しぶりにバズった自分の
投稿にちなみにこういうこともやってます
ので皆さんチェックしてくださいねと
ツイート塔子することアンコール
ファイナルファンタジー7のリメイクの
タイマータッグに挑むことミートがある
コーヒーを飲みたいけどスタバが見つから
ないその時に取る行動のことドトールも1
週間ネットフリックスも youtube
も見ないと決めて本当にそうすること
メンタル交際相手に自分の価値観を少し
ずつ押し付けていくことインストール
外国人に対して簡単すぎる日本語を使う
ことシンプル
me